okay we've got to talk now about Paul
Manafort at the beginning of the show we
talked about the eight guilty pleas from
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
and we are continuing coverage of August
21st 2018 yesterday a really bad day for
Donald Trump and his sort of
amalgamation of pond scum lowlifes and
grifters that he has surrounded himself
with despite the claim that he was going
to put the best people around him it is
not only Trump's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen who pleaded guilty to eight counts
but Paul Manafort Donald Trump's
campaign chairman one of the first major
indictments in Robert molars Trump
Russia investigation has been found
guilty on eight counts announced
yesterday he was actually up against 18
counts 10 of them ended up in a mistrial
with the jury unable to reach a verdict
but eight guilty verdicts against Paul
Manafort
five counts of tax fraud one charge of
hiding foreign bank accounts and two
counts of bank fraud eight total counts
the first major test of Robert Muller's
investigative team they did the
investigation they interviewed witnesses
they recommended charges and now they
got eight guilty verdicts in the first
big trial this is only the beginning for
Paul Manafort Paul Manafort is facing
another trial next month unrelated but
separate charges in Washington DC this
may only be the tip of the iceberg for
Paul Manafort now what will the
committed cognitively dissonant Trump
assay to defend this to excuse it to
claim that it's no big deal we actually
already know because they've been saying
it all along they'll say the same thing
that they said when the indictments were
first handed down which is these charges
don't relate to Russia and mana Ford's
actions as campaign manager for Donald
Trump yeah he's got a history in Russia
and he did sketchy stuff here and there
and of course in a sense that's true but
this is now a senior campaign official
with the means and the background and
the connections and the motive to help
the Russians and to push for collusion
with Russians and to push for the
Republican Party to soften its platform
on Russia which they did on the eve of
the Republican National Convention
back in 2016 it was because of this guy
so you have to take it a step at a time
despite Trump and his cronies claiming
that the investigation is almost over it
actually seems to be ramping up if
anything they've been saying it's almost
over for like a year now yet we keep
getting more indictments and guilty
pleas you need to prepare yourselves not
only for them to say this is very
clearly the end and it's not gonna go
any further you need to prepare
yourselves for headlines on right-wing
media like judge declares mistrial in
Paul Manafort trial ignoring that there
were eight guilty verdict or another
possible right wing headline is it time
to investigate Hillary Clinton's ties to
Paul Mann afford and I'm kind of joking
but then this morning I looked at the
Fox news.com headlines and you see that
the big story is the monster down the
road an illegal immigrant arrested in
the murder of Molly Tibbets who was a
local farmhand you see a story called a
lot a nerve about Alexandria Acacio
Cortes lamenting a café's closure over
wage hikes that she backs and then you
do see this very small story that has a
picture of Paul Manafort and of Michael
Cohen which says triple threat to GOP
storm clouds gather for GOP but midterm
surprises lurk the one reference to the
fact that trumps personal lawyer and
campaign manager were together found
guilty and pled guilty to 16 different
crimes was that despite this there could
still be some surprises for the
Republican Party in November of 2018
yeah so it's no surprise that Trump
supporters are just going to ignore this
and right-wing media is just going to
ignore this well oddly enough Trump
tweeted about it twice yesterday and I
don't know what why he's doing that
maybe because he could end up pardoning
Paul Manafort more because he
understands that Manta Ford has stuff on
Trump and they want to stay a part of
the same team so main affort doesn't
flip on and maybe signaling that just
hold tight and I'll eventually pardon
you yeah we also have a screenshot from
is it Breitbart iPad yep bright part
this morning the big story Tom cotton
Republicans
Tom cotton saying that Mali Tibbets
would be alive if the immigration laws
were seriously enforced and a bunch of
other stories and it's almost like
nothing really happened yesterday even
though August 21st was the worst day for
the Trump administration in the entire
time that it has existed as an
administration a lot of other big
stories apparently that Fox chose to
cover and Breitbart chose to cover
potential prison time okay
potential being the key word there are
people saying Paul Manafort is facing 80
years there are people saying Paul
Manafort is facing 240 years if you
count it in a different way
actual legal experts are saying the more
likely sentence would be in the range of
7 to 10 years in prison and of course
Trump pardons can change at all and
there is increasingly a very good chance
I believe that Donald Trump is going to
pardon manna for it I think he's
signaling it on Twitter already by
saying he's a good guy and this was all
unfair yeah and Paul Manafort 69 years
old I don't think he's gonna make it
another 240 years probably he's gonna
look for a way out
let's discuss Robert Muller's
investigation bigger picture number one
it's a victory for Muller ok the
investigation he is running is coming up
not only with charges because just
coming up with charges can happen
without them being charges that can be
proven the charges are sticking and the
charges are getting built guilty
verdicts both from juries and they are
also getting guilty pleas from people
like Michael Cohen and George
papadopolis that's already a big deal
second molars claims of biased behavior
are falling flat the closest that the
Wright got was Peter struck who was
caught texting anti-trump things molar
immediately dismissed him from the
investigation and struck has since been
fired by the FBI so despite all of the
smear attempts that are happening by the
trumpet on the right to discredit Robert
Muller he's run the investigation very
very well there's no demonstrable bias
that has been shown and most importantly
the charges are sticking and turning to
guilty verdicts which is always the
question when you've got such a massive
and highly explosive and politically
biased perspective on a trial like this
meanwhile Trump is stating again he
definitely didn't use the
word around Omarosa and the NFL players
should really stand during the national
anthem I'm kidding but full distraction
mode even doing like a presidential
rally yesterday this is not getting
better it's getting worse and I will
actually be answering questions about
what's going on with the investigation
on the show's Instagram account later on
if you're not following the show on
Instagram what are you doing with your
day I don't even know follow the show at
david pakman show on instagram and also
follow me at david dot pakman both on
instagram quick break after the break i
will be speaking to is gonna be very
exciting Pat I will be speaking to a
former Trump voter who has now turned on
Trump went on CNN and said I don't
support Trump anymore and started
receiving death threats from trumpets
claiming he was a CNN plant rather than
just a guy who doesn't support Trump
anymore Jeremy Montana's is going to
join me after the break
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman i love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the david pakman show I'm
sure you'll love politics and learning
and what blinka studs is take the best
and most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube i've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and i think you
will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about five
bucks a month you can go to be li NK
calm /pa KMA n to sign up